la verdad es que no hay muchas
esperanzas porque la retórica está
siendo por parte del gobierno ucraniano
no tiene muchas esperanzas porque los
combates siguen aquí en quiebra ciudad
sigue cercada al resto de ciudades están
siendo atacadas aunque se les que
asegura que no quiere perder una
oportunidad de parar esta guerra esta
guerra orquestada por vladimir putin así
que estamos un poco a la espera de saber
esas conversaciones es verdad que la
retórica también de rusia ha cambiado un
poco dice que quieren un acuerdo pero el
portavoz que han mandado a las
negociaciones no tiene un perfil muy
marcado de ser un negociador
diplomático pero de todas formas es
positivo es positivo que ambos bandos se
sienten a hablar en una zona neutral y
bueno luego la posición de bielorrusia
también hay que hay que destacar esa
posición que no está siendo neutral que
aunque lukashenko quiere una resolución
al conflicto sin embargo hay
informaciones de que siguen mandando
soldados y sigue mandando material que
éste se está utilizando en esta guerra